this guy actually start with that
breaking news the fire Nick was just
talking about in downtown Las Vegas yeah
so that lucky motel that's where we find
our Lauren negretti this is Maryland and
Fremont and Lauren you've got some new
information here within the last 20
minutes
I do yes good morning courtesy of Las
Vegas fire and rescue Battalion Chief
Joseph digitano he let me know the crew
was happening to leave another another
scene when they happened upon this one
an exterior fire that extended to the
side of the building that happened about
4 40 a.m this morning now took them 15
minutes to knock it down an hour to
clean up you can see behind me here just
some fire trucks here packing up as for
the most part they have left the area
they're just cleaning up here and
packing out now no Witnesses no people
inside Joseph let me know that they have
contacted management there was a partial
roof collapse but as for the cause of
the cause of the fire that is still
under investigation so we'll keep you
updated when we hear more here and on
8newsnow.com for now live near Maryland
Parkway and Fremont Street Laura
negretti 8 news now all right Lauren
thank you very much